[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ya pas mal tu te rouler dans la terre
battue
incroyable mais y'a pas vers la remontée
avec ses grands pas c'est quoi alors
comment ça va mon chéri savez vous
préviens on a conclu par un adolescent
difficile aux hauts cadres locaux comme
chaque semaine avec la séquence star du
paf quimera g et oui on adore ses 50 du
volume soit et pépé est un gars cette
semaine
non bon bah non cela est fort toi c'est
bien tous et bienvenue dans 50 secondes
insight upnp et on commence tout de
suite avec baba qui dansent sapé comme
jamais j'avais personnes mal mandela
était dedans s'est jamais arrêté
[Musique]
macbeth
comme existe alléluia les loups les
connaît pas les causes seront à
l'évidence il ne pourra pas pécho
delphine wespiser la chine cesse et il
faut du high level pour raisons je suis
trop les équipes tpp savent très bien
accueillir jean mais s'il ya way
bonjour bonjour bonsoir jean messia
d'être là en tout comme d'abord belle
embrouille jean messieurs c'est rester
focus et puis bernard montiel et gilbert
dassieu aussi savent rester focus ce
prix et cette semaine entre nicolas
pernikoff petit peu niveaux voisins
c'est chaud et amis bien hisser le
blonde à l'envers lorsque par la banque
elle fait une crise ado c'est sa team
qui joue la maman de temps que non
est-ce coupe cette semaine on a appris
que la mère de sa team était un très bon
de lire ma mère et de ma mère comme ça
il ya rien à dire bah bah c'est faire
des compliments aussi connu que non mais
c'est vrai que mandela qui est génial
mais de tf1 et puis 2 puis 6 euros m6 le
prochain à l'ordre de bruce accueillons
tout de suite
cyril à lille à mon pote le gitan à
c'est un gars curieux une gueule toute
noire des carreaux tout bleu il reste
des heures sans dire un seul mot assis
près du poêle au fond du bistrot mais
quand il fallait s'occupe du régime de
benjamin ça donne ça ça c'est pas tes
barres énergétiques à la suite de l'aja
membres ça tu sais ce que c'est simple
si ça trouve à l'est dans ton cul
benjamins terminent avec le conseil des
états unis c'est un mauvais exemple en
matière de santé c'est vrai à certains
égards mais oui mais c'est ainsi
qu'avant je peux vous dire qu'à la
blonde très très cher c'est un soutien
manger
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
d'autres sources du bébé est oui alors
j'essayais foire avec vous mais vous
avez vous quelques forts parce que à la
fois vous avez beaucoup de répartie
cyril mais vous savez que la chez les
gens non mais ce qui est encore plus
fort chez vous c'est que vous arrivez à
rire de vos propres vannes alors ça très
peu de masisi alors vous cacher beaucoup
de monde autour de la table mais
regardez bien la fin du magnéto parfois
et des petits rebelles non ouais c'est
dur moi je trouve effectivement de plus
en plus beau il a fait des lèvres bah
c'est sûr ils vous ressemblent de plus
en plus d'autres formes a parlé de ça
j'ai une anecdote trailer tout moment
rien à [ __ ] et je pensais que tu
pensais que je pouvais faire des choses
et berges en chalencon on le voit on le
voit obtenu que maintenant vous
travaillez chez darty
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
kanye b2b l'immédiat esthétique médias
et chirurgie esthétique c'est l'autre
cemac au moulage c'est bien sûr magali
bertin il arrive normalement on quitte
le vendredi ce canton la racolage en
appel et un prêt à tomber à 13 heures
l'une et venir another parce qu'il faut
augmenter tout ça c'est la seule famille
qu'est franchement vu ton niveau hier tu
peux rester chez toi
les gens qui viennent plus dans les pots
cassés
rassurez moi c'est pas songé qui coûte 4
millions parce que c'est vrai j'ai même
vu fait l'objet avec d'autres au total
la semaine prochaine sur vie d'organiser
un duel vont faire sa famille c'est pas
gagné d'avancé pour moi ouais chier dans
votre belle se chie dessus se chie
dessus c'est autre chose que d'être
animateur
non mais c'est pas moi c'est parce que
je vous aime
comment ça va vous au magazine moi ça va
très très bien regardez la voyez-vous
l'abri comme ça et pourtant il manque
une étagère et ça se voit on va faire
quoi niveau capillaire la bascule loi 1
on y on recherche non recherche web va
faire blanc j'aimerais bien qu'on laisse
un peu pousser
ouais vous laisser atteint clair
scellerie sinon on va laisser passer et
après on fera peut-être un bon cédric
peut-être aux roses c'était aussi rose
qu'on s'y arrête de lui coûter
non mais c'est vrai il en est proche
mais ça sert à rien cette relation il
faut qu'il joue qu'il fallait rentrer à
mulhouse par son mec et toi tu rentres
chez toi avorter ce qu'elle était et
c'est spaghettis à la carbonara elle en
train de te [ __ ] en l'air il tombe
bien guillaume genton à un avant avant
avant que le guen gens tombent bien oui
est ce que il ya une fille vous kiffez
au monde
ah ouais ma mère rester en vie de pécho
de faire bîmes tué alors les amoureux de
qui ne vous appris le bénin 4 il est
avec nous
[Musique]
m m merci de m merci beaucoup merci ça
fait très plaisir de vous rencontrer
merci beaucoup asseyez vous qu'est ce
qui se passe à challes base mais partie
des choses est obligé de continuer merci
à vous merci j'ai envie d'être là très
très grand avocat keita wim soit c'est
un honneur de l'avoir son asphalte aulas
je le dis merci d'être là merci beaucoup
lamberti à vos noms ça nous fait très
plaisir et ça nous touche beaucoup que
vous soyez là ce soir on va revenir sur
cette affaire qui entache et la
cérémonie miss france vous avez tout
nous raconter april merci d'être là en
tout cas ça fait longtemps qu'on voulait
vous à voir aussi sur le plateau et
merci d'être avec nous alors sache albaz
il est complètement fan de vous voilà
sachez le il est comme un fou comme de
valérie bénaïm de match
s'il te plaît voilà donc dans la
provence soit là il voulait que vous
assistiez à la fin de sa chronique du
trafic aux qui fait voilà et il veut
faire le beau devant vous des parties
encore deux ans plus tôt
alors vous allez voir le code dans un
instant par contre guillaume genton
guillaume genton on l'a cueilli à la
base'' il avait un look un peu différent
on va pas se mentir
alors du coup on a décidé d'observer
toutes ses tenues toutes ces coupes de
cheveux ces dernières semaines et cyril
a voulu reprendre les choses en main
sauf qu'en fait bas c'est pire en pire
c'est dramatique entendu ces histoires
qu'est ce qu'on avait pensé de son
lancement a pris pas mal elle n'aime pas
[Rires]
ça
[Musique]
dis moi qu'est ce qui se passe à lille
il est tout de cuir vêtu quoi 6,1 à
l'intérieur du suicide
et c'est beau tout ça c'est à dire voilà
comment ça va lui très bien aller il va
se changer frère avec les matières on
mettrait à nantes a piqué un canapé dans
un club de gym et les mêmes on a même un
petit nouveau puisque regard des ados
[Rires]
voilà qui change
il paraît que c'est la grande mode voilà
mais aussi il a son jean marc comme jeff
pas d'accord cebu ligne rose poudré qui
fait mouche mise de bowling qui fait
seul instant d'avoir moment un groupe
oui quand même s'est quand même bien
lucas genton et nos retraités cgt chez
le coloriste amadouer espèce de châtain
foncé j'ai passé très bien j'ai bossé
tout le week-end toi tu partes tout de
suite en enquêtes policières temps à
perdre
c'est le seul cas il fait une émission
il en est
guillaume genton barbie
[Applaudissements]
il est c'est bon mais fonctionne il est
très très bon match et cucq hélas
erronée et cécilia rené cécilia qui oui
c'est julien
rien
alerte enlèvement nous sommes toujours à
la recherche de la dignité de guillaume
genton si vous avez des informations
merci de nous contacter c'est un grand
joueur ici joue le jeu c'est pour ça que
ce n est tout va merci vraiment et c'est
ce que je retiens tout va ah non c'est
incroyable je vais tenter de nouvelles
choses bientôt 90 ans maire de patron
tant m pas vraiment dans ces bons
sherman oaks a beaucoup plus en tout cas
à notre avocat a pris le pas du tout je
crois que m veux le même t-shirt avec le
jeu c'est très cher c'est cyril et
benjamin vous prions coller les vacances
ici bon c'est bien donc c'est que c'est
pas un club de vacances avec l âge mon
mariage
non parce que alors pas du tout cherté
spectateur j'ai observé les voix mais
pas bien je suis très bons plans crises
d'asthme en effet mais non mais bon donc
j'ai observé les histoires de benjamin
castadi et si elle il me saoule
j'observais les galéjades de ses deux
animateurs ils sont partis complètement
en sucette cette semaine regardez j'en
ai l'impression qu'ils ont 405 sur un
green où ils apprennent vous connaissiez
sacha ou pas du tout non non je ne
connaissais pas vous avez connu mais je
les ai vus dans l'émission quelques fois
mais maintenant je n'avais jamais
rencontré
d'accord ça vous a fait quelque chose
que vous l'avez rencontré michel relou
merci la france c'est parfois oui mais
j'ai vraiment j'ai souvent les contacter
sur un stade absolument parce baisse de
mythos je le jette alors je sens nous
avons tellement nul pas par contre n'ont
par contre elle elle a gentiment lac est
une de mes publications la semaine
dernière non très loin des bassins
désolé vous avez acquis s'il le dit
c'est que c'est très gentiment mais non
mais si on sait déjà que c est la ahl
al-haq et publications moi ça y est les
partis très loin
non mais je peux vous montrer mes dm je
n'ai absolument pas draguer après le
benayoun pas de là qu on la tue mamie tu
m'a écrit un message d alerte 6 mois
c'est castaldi castaldi bâtard bien la
semader pernikoff
[Musique]
là je t'aime tu peux pas le faire à gym
tu peux faire à j'imagine je me vois tu
t'es bien musclés se peut faire un truc
non mais je vois tu vois là je te dis
c'est musclé ici
avant on sait d'avancé quand tu es trop
recommander cette impression de la
ténarèze web on sait on avait juste de
notre gueule encore combien de temps m
non mais sans rire et vous vous parlez
akira moi à oui bon ok ce qui va se
passer je l'adorent semaines maintenant
les nazis fait un plaisir tant villa non
mais là le
asca ça castagne wah wah wah tu tu
n'avoues pas mal aux bovins castaldi
c'est le plus gros délit donc si jamais
quand il m'avait donc dans mon scénario
pas toi mon cul au le [ __ ] 10000
points
nicolas tu l'as eu la totale ou pas tu
l'avais hôtel mon cul les deux bilans et
la maintenance a été menée le coup je
rappelle que je voulais les arbres et
les coulisses j'en vois une photo après
cyril savez un bleu ben on s'adore voilà
des mois et là son jeu vous le verrez il
en a fait un mètre division historique
sera la semaine prochaine voilà version
qui sait juste pas une monnaie appréciée
les pires qu'un tir debout
[Rires]
april parents qui touche là